[Music]
good evening i'm kevin kelly
of the long nail foundation
i'm your substitute host for this
evening usually stuart brand
hosts this but he is in
scrambling along the nile in egypt
exploring a long now adventure on the
world's longest river
so
yes our topic tonight is artificial
intelligence and i don't think that um
i have
been at a dinner
in the last four years where the
conversation at some point during the
dinner did not touch upon ai
nor have i given a talk
in the last
five years where the question of ai has
not come up
that suggests to me
that
the importance of artificial
intelligence is appreciated
all over the world we all understand
that this is perhaps one of the most
important things
that we're doing
at the same time
the uncertainty about
where it's going to go and what's going
to lead to
is just as high
and it's this pairing of absolute
certainty of the importance of this and
the absolute uncertainty
of what it will do and what it will mean
that has brought us to this moment where
we want to talk about the possible ways
of ai and to do that we have a different
format this evening than we usually do
i'm going to introduce john brockman who
is a curator and an editor
who likes to
take some of his literary clients of
which i am one and steward is another
and all the people on stage tonight
use john to represent him represent them
but he is someone who likes to take
thinking intellectuals scientists who
can talk to the public and have them
talk to each other
and
through that conversation explore
reality and so
he's going to have a conversation with
three
natural intelligences
who are experts in cognition
and
for about 12 minutes each they'll talk
and then um
i'm going to come back up and i'll ask
some questions and then i'll represent
the questions that you have written on
the cards very legibly
and um we'll have a conversation in a
larger sense
so
um
let's think about the ways in which
this certain world of ai
could be explored and john's book which
he's just edited is called
possible minds
25 ways to think about ai
the people who are here this evening the
three of them
uh each have a
different vision of ai and we're going
to hear about those and together we'll
try to think about
the ways in which this inevitable future
is coming and how it could play out so
john would you like to take over
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you uh as
kevin said i'm the editor of the volume
i did not write it
but here we are in this theater and i
guess i have to talk about it
which is fitting because
my aspiration
has always been to be the guy at the
back of the theater that turns the
lights on and turns them off
and that's a good place to start because
in 1965
i was approached by
the late jonas meccas who only died two
weeks ago at the age of 96
and he said
we'd like to hire you to
come in in my absence
as i have to go home to latvia
and
run a festival
uh based on cinema because this is
filmmaker cinema tech which was the home
of avant-garde theater
and uh and cinema
we want you
to take this list of 50 artists which
included andy warhol robert rauschenberg
namjoon bake
happenings artists alan capro carolee
schneemann
minimal
uh
musicians like lamont young and terry
riley
and
each of them
can do an event
it has fifty dollars you can hand out to
them and um
make sure it's somehow connected to
cinema
and
i took the job we ran the festival it
was
an astonishing success to the extent the
the big result
ultimately
had
a
big effect
was in disco
uh
that twirling defection grading ball
that you dance under
every time you see it just think of me
because uh
village voice said
the events that we were running then
was the beginning of the age of disco so
that's
i want to go down with that one
so what does this have to do with
cybernetics
uh what happened uh
for example the usko group
showed up there was a
guy named uh garrett stern
uh was an anonymous group of guild
artists
uh musicians writers poets
uh
they lived in a psychedelic psychedelic
tabernacle and it was there in 1965 i
met
a young
satellite guy to that group his name was
stuart brand
and
that was
54 years ago when we've been in touch
regularly
ever since you know
even three weeks ago in new york when he
got clobbered in a debate
uh some of you might have seen
and stuart is has always been cooking
and stuart and i uh
had a
mutual interest in something that was
going on at the cinema tech
in 965
that i had no idea about is all the
scientists
all the artists were reading science
and that was the bright young 24 year
old
and robert rauschenberg
said take this and it was
one two three infinity by robert kemp by
george gamoff
and
kleis ol klaus oldenburg the sculptor
gave me one two three infinity by j
james jeans
and all of them were reading nova wiener
maybe not maybe not warhol but uh
wiener's ideas were everywhere the idea
of the non-linear relationship be
between input and output and at the same
time
luckily uh you have these things happen
in your life that change everything
i met john cage the composer philosopher
who was organizing a
monthly dinner of young artists
and five or six of us would meet at the
home of
the founder of the fluxus art movement
to kick ins and
we sit there cage would make his
beer recipes beer and mushroom recipes
and
feed us and then feed us the ideas he
was thinking about he was working on a
book then called
a year from monday and what he was
interested in was primarily weiner
and he also
talked a lot about claude shannon and
von neumann
and
particularly marshall mcluhan
and and those were breathtaking evenings
that affected everybody there and
certainly
i got intensely excited and this went on
for about eight months and
at one point cage reached into his
knapsack and pulled out a book and
handed to me he said this is for you
and
cybernetics by noble weiner okay i took
the book
he never talked to me again
after three or four
meetings i
asked dick higgins the host what
so
and he said john he's a zen master you
don't need him
so
that was that
i went on my way
and um
while i was at the cinematic
something else very interesting called
the phone rang
it was
someone named ak solomon head of
biophysics at harvard and
also in the film was walter rosenblith
sensory
communications researcher at mit
and solomon explained that two of them
were weiner's best friends
weiner had died
some months before
and
they were puzzled they've been reading
all these many articles the new york
times about
the activities at the cinema techs which
were which were getting worldwide
publicity
and um
why is weiner involved in this what is
what
what do we have to do with this
and
they didn't know i didn't know anything
about science
uh
and
they
said let's have a meeting and
why don't you bring your artists to
cambridge and
we'll get together and we'll have a
discussion
and we did and it was
the oscar group terry riley who is
became the inspiration for brian eno
um
ken dewey of theater x
about eight of us went up and we spent
two days talking with
solomon who at that time was jared
diamond's thesis advisor which i only
found out recently
anthony ettinger
uh walter rosenblatt and harold doc
edgerton
vented the stroboscope
none of them were computer scientists
because there were no computers
but the big event was they took us to
see the computer
um
we walk into this huge space in which
isolated in the middle is a cold room
which is raised up about a foot
and
it has wood and then there's glass
and inside the room are all these people
scurrying around wearing white coats and
gloves it was really cold and
i remember walking up to the window
my nose against the window
and
my breath
uh
steaming things up watching this
enormous machine spitting out cards and
people running back and forth and
i fell in love
and
that's why i'm here and
this is not my book we have some very
bright people here to talk about it and
the point of this book is
uh was supposed by we started out having
a meeting uh in
um
washington connecticut uh because i
picked up wiener's other book
the human use of human beings which
strangely um i was on my way out on a
nice summer day
and i said i'll grab a book and i'd
never read it before i realized been in
my library for all these years where
where
cybernetics by norbert weiner
two years
after i first read it at the cinema tech
i came to menlo park and to see my
friend stuart and the two of us sat in a
corner in november 67 while lois
brando's wife the mathematician was the
person doing the whole earth catalog
stuart and i
sat in a connor reading
underlining annotating discussing
cybernetics by norbert weiner and that
experience has been with me
for 54 years and that's what i've been
doing
and here i am
so
that's it for my introduction
and
uh we're going to hear from
rod brooks uh
alex gopnik and stewart russell in
alphabetical order
and uh
am i supposed to do introductions
uh rod
what can you say about rod uh if you
want to be a credentialed person in a
world where credentials don't matter as
much anymore
and and
be attacked for being elitist
he was the chairman of computer science
at mit then he was the chairman of
computers of the ai lab at mit i don't
see
how you get better than that but
today as neil gershenfeld points out in
the book
um any freshman in neil's courses
has in his pocket
his startup plan that he's willing to
show his professor and
leave the university for the startup
uh and that's
to some degree who we have running a lot
of these companies um that are
uh in the mainstream today and doing
very well so who knows
uh rod recently
uh
uh
was running a robotics company prior to
that he is the man behind the roomba
vacuum cleaner
and um
[Applause]
rob brooks
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks john you know i i started out by
doing a degree in pure mathematics and i
ended up being a vacuum cleaner salesman
things are going really well
so you've been talking about the
the lack of responsibility that the
platforms are taking
vis-a-vis issues such as privacy or even
the future of computation
do you like to
yes i think um
you know
hacking back to normal weiner's uh a
book on the on the uh
the second book that you mentioned wena
had been looking at cybernetics at a
time when machines were physical stuff
you could see and he introduced control
theory it had come out of his work
during the second world war on
controlling uh
aiming systems for guns but you could
see the components you could see how
they were connected and he was at a time
trying to apply that sort of thinking to
the
to how animals worked how animals and
humans worked physical understanding and
at the same time
turing and von neumann were
introducing the idea of computation
and computation was very different you
can't really see the components you
don't have a good intuition uh you know
from your childhood of how how the
pieces fit together
there were very different methodologies
for thinking about
animals and humans and intelligence and
by the way stuart i think in another 50
years we'll have an equally different
way of thinking about things so things
are going to change
but this new way of thinking
computational thinking you can't see the
components and you can't see how they
fit together but at the same time we had
moore's law where computation was
getting more and more doubling every
year or two
and we had to exploit it and so the
engineering that used to be based on
physical components was now based on
these information components that you
couldn't really see or understand
and that pressure of moore's law said
anyone who can
can exploit moore's law is going to make
a lot of money do a lot of things
and so we sort of gave up on the normal
engineering principles and we have built
as a result
systems which are not very secure and
we've given over our control of our
world to those
insecure systems
which
well
it's all about universality and knowing
and architectures i won't go into that
but the second thing that's happened
is that we went from a world where
there was an interaction to recording
the interactions and so now
it's not just what the interaction is at
one point but it's the record of
interactions and that is how we've given
up gave up our security now we've given
up our privacy and
that is being exploited in ways that
none of us would let
a person
know about everything we did we wouldn't
let them look over our shoulder at
everything we did
unless we trusted them uh
with everything of our lives but when
we're talking to our machines we don't
sort of see that in the background all
these pieces of information have been
correlated and we have lost our privacy
and that's how we're being exploited in
your chapter you a little more jaundiced
you were oh well we you weren't naming
names but you were
explicitly talking about the
communication platforms have become a
shield behind which some companies hide
in order to inhumanly exploit others and
i think roger mcnamee may have talked
about that failure and you also said
humankind has gotten itself into a fine
pickle
we are being exploited by companies that
paradoxically
deliver services we crave and at the
same time our lives depend on many
software-enabled systems open to attack
getting ourselves out of this mess will
be a long-term project it will evolve
engineering legislation and most
important moral leadership moral
leadership is the first and biggest
challenge but legislation
in the west coast
well we we have lived for hundreds of
years with legislation about engineered
systems we had you know in the in the
great days of the train systems being
introduced in the uk there was
legislation about
safety so we have had that i think you
know many people someone said to me
tonight oh you and stuart are going to
disagree uh uh
vociferously who's this steward well
there's sure it's going to be a couple
of people after me stewart russell um
but i think i think um i think
although stuart thinks it's about super
intelligence i think it's about pretty
straightforward dumb stuff is what is
getting us
and it's the exploitation by the way um
uh
weiner thought was was worried in his
book he was worried about how these
mechanical systems were going to make us
humans just cogs in the system he's
viewed that level of control but the
level of control is much more subtle and
and less explicit
it's sort of an accidental byproduct
but he was he was analog he didn't think
he didn't yes know about computers but
the prescience
of what he was talking about in the
human use of human beings
we talked about
we must not kiss the hand that
holds
holds the whip
you know
in his book he had a
a chapter which george dyson pointed out
to me
in his 1950
first edition
which was expunged
four years later because
he went after
scientists that were exploiting
technology
for and and his two best friends were
shannon who were going to work at rca
and monoi men who were going to work at
ibm
so
that's in you went to work at roomba
yeah
yeah
but now you're now you're not associated
you're not the uh rumba professor at uh
no no no i i i i moved on from vacuum
cleaners to
with my next company um someone studying
the human uh the biome was using uh my
robot backstab to unpack stool samples
so i continued to
decline
all right so we're talking about uh
some of your responses to the climate
today but in terms of your own
scientific work
this book is called possible minus 25
ways of looking at ai why is your way
different
well i i really in in this particular
book i really concentrated on on
my essay on weiner's
worries and how they had turned out to
be
expressed in a different way but in
terms of possible minds i'm much more
interested today
in
how we have
across
lots of areas of science
taking computation as our metaphor for
what's going on and it's the that's just
what everyone does now neuroscience
computational neuroscience computation
is the metaphor
by the way
the computation metaphor of
maturing as expressed by von neumann and
then
hop craft doorman
knuth etc that computational metaphor
the fundamental
metaphor of computation no longer holds
for our computers it turns out
that is why we had the recent
two attacks
spectra and another one
on all our
intel-based processes because they don't
they no longer maintain
that
that abstraction of computation
but we think computation is the tool
that we will work with when i was very
young
the tool for thinking about
the metaphor for thinking about the
brain uh in the books that i read as a
child were a
telephone switching network and then
they became a computer then they became
a massively parallel computer in earlier
times we had had a a hydrodynamic system
in their head
at all times we take the the most uh
technically advanced thing out there and
use that as the metaphor for thinking
and i think we probably haven't quite
got it right yet
um the names of the world are the life
of the world
nature is not created it's said
and so
this brain is a computer yes
um when your brain isn't a computer
you know it's a neural network or
people take dr takes blood that's who
you are
um
very
interesting to see where we'll go
by the way even back in the cybernetics
days people were and if you read the uh
as you referred to him i think in the
introduction you read the macy
conferences which were the
scientificians working together they
were very taken with mcculloch and pitts
from 1943 describing how
the neurons were logical elements which
is what has led to neural networks but
if you go back and read that 1943 paper
it was pure supposition by this uh
by pitts
in chicago
uh where was that well yeah
the first paper in the mesa conferences
wasn't on cybernetics it was in 42 it
was on neural inhibition yeah and then
and when colin competing 43 tried to
connect that with logic it's interesting
that mcculloch and pitts were electrical
engineers
um
they were the ones that were insistent
of elena's objections that
mine have a place
in cybernetics um
and they recruited gregory baker and
margaret mead
to
based on their work um
in basins with navin
in the in
and they were present at every
conference but at a certain point
the engineers and the systems and
ecologically
minded people
went one way
and the others went the other way
and
once digital came in around 1961
a two the digital engineers
knew what they were doing and
the cybernetics stuff was a dead end it
just wasn't relevant but the ideas were
the ideas survived they are the world we
live in
we don't have to use words cybernetic
anymore but you have
an entire generation of
generations of people for 40 years that
were clueless about the intellectual
landscape that all this comes from
and that's what i hope to accomplish
with this book
so so for me you were sort of asked what
i was
you know thinking about for ai
for me it's how did those ideas the
ideas of ashby etcetera designed for a
brain
coming out of cybernetic
tradition
what aspects did they capture that the
computational models don't capture and
is there something there that can lead
to a set of a new set of ideas because i
think that current um what's currently
called ai machine learning deep learning
is a very narrow slice really based on
that
weighing all the way back to that
mcculloch and pitts paper from 43
and is probably missing an enormous
amount of what will be necessary if
we're going to build
real ai systems but meanwhile i'm
worried about the security and privacy
getting us long before that
good
thank you thank you
[Music]
alison
so
uh when i interview people on the edge
website
if any of you have watched these
interviews
you don't hear me like i do
talk occasionally but basically i try to
say nothing
i always ask the people
there's one question
what is the question you're asking
yourself
um
today the reason is uh we don't talk
about books on the site even though i
make my living
in the book business
uh becomes a bustman's holiday this is a
way i get to talk to people and not have
to look at them as money
so
so
analogously to that i'm not going to ask
you what are the questions you're asking
yourself
which are very different
than an author in a book tour who's
talking about what they were thinking
about four years ago
when they proposed a book
um
like to stay in the present and so in
this regard
talk about what's different about the
way you're looking at this whole field
so actually what rodney was saying at
the end of his conversation it was a
great setup for the sort of things that
that we're working on so there's been
this enormous excitement
justified excitement about what's
happened in the past five or six years
in machine learning and ai but i think
there's an increasing sense that people
are coming up against the limits of what
some of these techniques can actually do
that in fact it's
remarkably powerful but very narrow
compared to the kinds of things that
any human being and the human beings
that i study are three and
four-year-olds that any three and
four-year-old that any three and
four-year-old can do and what i think
more and more people are trying to think
about is could we get
both clues from uh looking at say very
young children for designing ai that
could overcome those limitations and
also are there ways that we could
understand human beings including very
young children and in particular how can
we understand this amazing thing about
human beings which is that we
have these little disturbances of air at
our eardrums and photons hitting the
back of our retinas and yet somehow we
go from that to learn all the things
that we know about the world including
learning about computers and quarks and
distant objects and the people who do
that most of that learning most
effectively are the people who are
sitting there under our feet being
ignored
up to up to about age four so there's a
really interesting
question on both sides how do we as
human beings learn as much as we do and
how can we actually design artificial
systems that could learn that involves
putting together those two these two
things that you wouldn't normally think
would go together and then of course
there's a worry about whether the
machines are going to blow up and kill
us all but that's kind of you know i'll
leave that for stewart and raw too to
worry about at least for now
so you you
and by the way the analogy to toddlers
might be relevant here like right you
really like you probably don't wanna i
think three-year-olds are unbelievably
smart but you probably don't want to
give them the keys to the nuclear
to your nuclear weapons which is sort of
analogous to the ai issues
so
allison is known for
theory of mine and she's one of the top
cognitive scientists in the world and
it's always
been interesting to me why all these
ones and zeros people
are running the show
literally
without any sense of psychology without
any sense of the definition of
intelligence in this book there are
people like
stephen pinker or
rob brooks
that are talking about coming at it from
the intelligence angle
and yourself
uh but so much of it is about
engineering
and i just don't get it like well you
know it's funny john my experience in
the past in the past several years when
i've been i've been talking to to
computer scientists for
20 years but particularly with this new
excitement is that in some ways
engineers are more open-minded than
scientists are scientists tend to
scientists tend to really
develop a theory about what the world is
like or what the mind is like and really
want to hold on to it really ferociously
and to some extent there's something
good about the engineering attitude that
says oh you think the mind is different
from the way that i've been thinking
about the mind and you think that could
help us to learn better fabulous great
i'm gonna do something different from
what i've been doing before and you can
see this even if you look at the
development of the new deep learning
techniques for example lots of people
who are not using those techniques who
were using trying to use more abstract
kinds of representations said oh wait a
minute these things are really exciting
and they work really well and they're
really powerful but now as i say we're
coming up against the limitations and i
think the limitations are things like
being able to creatively think up new
ideas so what these techniques are
incredibly good at doing is pulling out
complicated statistical structure from
very big data sets and i don't think
anybody realized that having really big
data sets and having really powerful
computers and just essentially doing
this really relatively simple thing as
as rod was saying something that goes
back to mccullough and pitts of being
able to pull out statistical structure
could let us do all these things that we
couldn't do we couldn't do before but
that's still a very very different
process even though we call it learning
from the kind of learning that say kids
are doing every day where you can give
kids three examples not five million
examples and then what they'll conclude
from that is something a nice example
you mentioned theory of mind right so um
you can give kids very little data and
they'll be able to figure out something
like here's what this person believes
here's what this person thinks here's
what this person wants and i can
make a brand new inference about what
the person wants and what the person
believes and what they'll do completely
unlike anything that anybody has ever
said before
just with a tiny tiny bit of data and
that's exactly the opposite of the sort
of strengths and weaknesses of the
current exciting ai where you've got
enormous amounts of data and not very
good generalization to to new examples
with kids you've got tiny bits of data
and amazing generalizations so one of
the things one of the stories i talked
about one of the great things about
being a developmental cognitive
scientist is that you can get to tell
cute stories about your grandchildren
and nobody can stop you because you're a
cognitive scientist
time
so
so i learned that from matt whitaker in
the five-minute clock
um
so my grandson was talking four-year-old
grandson was talking to his grandfather
who said i want to be a kid again
and auggie very quietly said well maybe
you should stop eating broccoli and
green beans and healthy vegetables
grandpa
and just stop eating all that stuff and
you could be a kid again and of course
if you think about it that's actually a
very rational hypothesis right because
if you eat all that stuff then you grow
up to be a big grown-up so maybe if you
stop eating all that stuff you could go
back to being a kid
and that's not just my adorable cute
grandson that's what four-year-olds do
all the time and that's actually what we
study when we do our work we can give
the kids a little bit of data about a
system and they can make causal
inferences about that system that that
are more impressive than the greatest
scientists that we know
and that kind of capacity is the kind of
capacity that capacity for creative
generation of a new idea that nobody's
had before
if you want human intelligence that's
the thing that we humans can do better
than anyone else well better
maybe the only people that can do that
only
i don't know you tell me is
the advance into novelty specific to
humans that
you know
can an ai come up with something
that never been
thought of before well you know to some
extent they can make new generalizations
they can think up new test moves they
can figure out a a new way of playing go
but those are still very restricted
can they have can they have humor um
well you know it depends the trouble is
all these things that are most
distinctively human are exactly the
things that we have we have the hardest
time uh we have the hardest time
defining but here's the thought actually
i'm actually teaching this this book in
my class we were talking about it today
and here's a thought which is if you
think about something like ai's in the
legal system which is something that
people are very worried about now
because an ai could actually be making
decisions about things like what a
sentence should be
the thing about human beings isn't so
much that we can take a bunch of data
and say this person has broken the law
or not
what we can do is we can say you know
maybe this law isn't the right law even
though this is the generalization this
is the data that i can see about the way
that we've done things for the last
thousands a thousand years and i can set
up an objective function and say i'm
going to get an ai to do the same thing
we've been doing the amazing thing that
people can do is they can say but maybe
that's completely wrong maybe that's in
science we can say maybe that's
completely the wrong way about of
thinking about the world in ethics we
can say
maybe that's the wrong way of thinking
about how we should have humans thriving
the the great huck finn example about
well i'll go to hell because i'm
violating the the conventions of the
people around me because i i i help
i helped jim to be to be free that that
seems to me to be really the essence of
what human beings can do this kind of
constant bootstrapping and revising and
taking the place that we are now in in
conjunction with other people having
conversations that let us get to some
place that's new and
you know i do think the brain is a
computer presumably we do know about
physical systems that can do this in
fact we can actually create physical
systems that can do this kind of really
sophisticated learning um
and it's much more fun than programming
because these are actually the
four-year-olds who are around us we have
really good techniques for creating them
so we can do this but we don't on so
that those are real physical systems
that are out there in the world at some
point we're going to understand them but
i think the key it's going to be this
capacity for novelty this capacity to
bring things into the world or make
worlds that were that were totally
different from the worlds that were
there before um
and can you give an example or two of
in your work how you see
cognitive science connecting
to yeah ai experiments
so there's been this tension that's been
there in not just in cognitive science
but in philosophy going back to plato
and aristotle between two different ways
of solving this great problem of
knowledge how is it that from those
little photons and disturbances we can
figure out how the world works and one
idea has always been if we just have
enough data if we just take the data and
we put it together in complicated enough
ways we're going to solve the problem
and that's kind of been the deep
learning approach another approach has
been to say let's
think about what would happen if we
had abstract representations of the
world to begin with if we knew something
about the world and we understood the
world in a pretty abstract sophisticated
kind of way and then we revised those
abstract representations rather than
trying to to just start from scratch
just from nothing but the evidence in
our eyes and ears and that's that that
we've sort of ping-ponged back and forth
in the history of ai between those two
approaches indeed in the history of
philosophy which is you know my other
day job we've ping pong back and forth
between those two approaches and i think
we're starting to have some of the tools
to have systems that genuinely do both
of those things that can go back and
forth from
very abstract structured representations
of the world and those are the things
that let us make
brand new predictions to
the actual data that we get from the
world and there are things like
probabilistic
generative models that we've been using
ways of trying to search those spaces
that can help to
represent the kinds of things that we
think that children are doing
causal inference is something that
children do
constantly pretty much from the time
they're born and that's something that's
different from just statistical uh from
just pulling out statistics and that's
something that uh that computers are
gonna have to do if they're if they're
gonna have something like human
intelligence that's connected to do
today approvals exactly that's right so
for 20 years we've been using causal
causal graphical models judea pearl
talks about them in uh in the book we've
been using that kind of formalism the
book of why yeah to try to understand to
try to understand what's going on with
uh with even very young children so i
think that peace being able to
understand the causal structure of the
world is going to play a big role
another thing that i think is going to
play a a big role
is um
the very fact of childhood so one of the
most distinctive things about us as
human beings and this is true about big
brained animals in general is we have
this very long helpless useless period
of childhood when we're making lots of
new connections and then we have this
kind of tipping point where we become
adults and one of the things that i
think is really interesting is thinking
about a lot of things that we might
think of as bugs of childhood like
noisiness and randomness and craziness
and weirdness and actually thinking that
those might be the features that in
combination with the things we can do as
adults being controlled and goal
directed
that that that kind of secret starting
out one way and then with one kind of
intelligence and then having another
kind of intelligence that might be the
secret so rather than thinking about
general artificial intelligence which is
always the thing that people think about
we might want to think about lots of
different intelligences multiple
intelligences including like possible
minds yeah including the intelligence of
kids
thank you
all for jumping
[Music]
stuart russell is next
berkeley professor
if you've ever taken a computer science
class you've used his textbook which
has sold five million copies a few of
which have been paid for
so um
stewart is my default person for
asking serious questions about
computation he's
recognized authority
in the general field and has done
important work and bounded rationality
and also ai risk
and
and
kind of beneficial what would you call
it
uh so beneficial ai beneficial
alignment yeah so he's one of the good
guys
yeah so um
i started worrying about this actually
uh a long time ago
um
because my uh
my parents lived in birmingham and
um
they sold their house to david lodge
who's a
author who writes um
sort of academic romances and and things
like that and um
so um
so david gave us a couple of his books
and i read
changing places and small world
and
so in
in the story there's a graduate student
who
goes to the big
literary theory conference
uh and there's a panel of the
the gods of his field uh up there and he
asked the question he says basically you
know what if you were right
and this causes absolute consternation
uh because
you know if you know anything about
literary theory the idea that it could
be right or wrong
uh is sort of missing the point
completely uh it's all about destroying
the other person's uh reputation and and
and uh and so on so anyway um
and i thought i should read this because
the other the other part of the book is
about uh
uh academics who move from a fictional
version of birmingham to a fictional
version of berkeley
uh and since i was moving from the real
birmingham to the real berkeley it was
like this is a funny sort of coincidence
and and
this made me pay attention to that
question and i was thinking what if you
asked people in ai
what if you were right what have you
actually succeeded
in the goals that you have set for the
field
and it seemed to me that
almost no one was asking that question
and certainly nobody had an answer
and over the that was in the early 90s
and over the next
20 years or so
i started to think about what kinds of
answers you might have and it became i'd
say a little bit more urgent
for me when i saw big dog which is the
boston dynamics the four-legged robot
which you see in that video where the
one of their engineers tries to push it
over
uh basically kicks this robot tries to
push it to the ground with his foot
um so he's probably the first to go
and uh you know and i and i and it it
actually you know it sort of recoils and
stumbles and then gets back on its feet
again in such a lifelike way and i had
worked on leg locomotion in the 90s and
it's a hard problem
and you look at that video and you think
okay
that problem is basically solved you
know what if we solve some of the other
problems like the problems that alison
was talking about
um the problems of uh dexterous
manipulation for robots which is another
big open problem in the field
the problem of understanding language
what if we actually nail these problems
and and to some extent uh we've now
largely nailed the problem of speech
recognition
and in some ways although in very
fragile and peculiar ways we saw the
problem of recognition of objects in
visual images
and
if you've ever used google translate
these days machine translation seems to
work incredibly well so we're starting
to nail some of these problems
and
so this has made me think harder
and here's the problem
that i see
we have what you might call the standard
model so physics has its standard model
and ai has a standard model and it's the
same standard model that control theory
has that cybernetics has
that statistics has that economics has
operations research it's the same model
you create optimizing machinery
for which you specify an objective
and then you hope
that you got the objective right
and
so interestingly uh
so john was talking about the book by
norbert weiner human use of human beings
um and in that book he says
uh the purpose that we put into the
machine
has to be the purpose that we really
desire
otherwise we're toast
right
and um
so that's the standard model this is how
we do things this is you know a big
chunk of 20th century technology is
based on that model
and
we know also said
that it's only human impotence that has
protected us from human folly
um by which he meant that our machines
are so stupid and and uh they
have impacts on such a small scale that
if you put the wrong purpose in up to
now you've been able to switch them off
reset
uh you know hit yourself on the head and
say okay obviously i forgot
uh you know i forgot about this i forgot
about that so
the question is
when machines are more intelligent than
human beings we may not have that choice
and uh and even before that
so we talked about social media so raj
was was saying that we are sort of at
the mercy of social media and
you know and the filter bubble is
something that people talk about right
it's a
um it's a phenomenon and the the word
filter bubble is very much looking at it
from the point of view of the human
being who's who's in it
uh and how it affects your opinions over
time
but
look at this from the point of view of
the machine right what is the purpose
put into the machine the purpose is
maximize click through
right feed people stuff that they're
going to click on because that's how we
make money
right and you might say well how do you
maximize click through
you just send people stuff that they
like clicking on right
simple as that actually that's not what
the algorithms are doing
that's probably what facebook and google
and so on thought that the algorithms
were going to do
that the algorithms would adjust to the
people's preferences
but in fact
that's not how reinforcement learning
works reinforcement learning changes the
state of the world to maximize the
reward
and the state of the world in this case
is your brain
so what does it do it changes you in a
way that makes you more predictable so
that
it can then
send you stuff that it knows you're
going to click on
and who is more predictable than a
raving fascist or a raving communist
right so the algorithms simply operate
in a straightforward way to push you
know so whichever whatever side of the
spectrum you're on it's going to push
you to the extreme by feeding you
algorithms that are a little bit to the
left or a little bit to the right of
where you currently are and it does that
very efficiently uh and creates raving
fascists and raving communists who will
then lap up all of the raving content
that that
that the world can produce and there's
there's a whole industry you know that
has grown up simply to feed that process
um so
that simple algorithm is not very smart
it's a reinforcement learning algorithm
um has
possibly destroyed the eu
nato uh western democracy
um
and that's just 50 lines of code right
imagine
you know
imagine if it was if it was a really
intelligent system operating
um so
this is so this is the problem that we
face and the question is you know
what do we do about that
and we just say get rid of the standard
model
right the standard model
where
the machine operates with a fixed
objective provided by humans
and a different model
is
to have machines whose purpose is to
make
life better for humans but doesn't know
what that means in other words they are
explicitly un uncertain of what the true
objective is and when you
change the model to that
right you create a kind of a coupling
between machines and humans the machines
remain dependent on humans because it's
the humans who have the objective
right the machines would like to know
what it is but we're not telling them do
you think and that's it and that that
creates them they become subservient
necessarily subservient they necessarily
ask permission
they necessarily allow themselves to be
switched off because they want to avoid
doing things that we don't like
and so on so you change the relationship
completely will we get
ai that
um
doesn't know what it doesn't know
uh
that so that would be a mistake right we
we need the ai systems to know that they
don't know
uh yeah so is that possible yes that's
that's uh that's entirely possible is it
possible to get an ai with humility
in the sense that yes
uh catherine bateson points out wouldn't
it be great
if an ai
system
uh was presented with a problem and said
i'll sleep on it
at the very least so um
[Music]
the
uh yeah so the kind of humility we're
talking about
um
came into ai
sometime around 1980 actually there was
a there was a single issue of the ai
journal
where all of the logical ai people who
up to that point had assumed that ai
systems could have perfect correct
knowledge of the world
basically fessed up and said okay not
really
we can't do that we have to have some
form of uncertainty and they came up
with all kinds of weird
stuff
uh anything to avoid probability and uh
and judo pearl said no no probability is
fine and here's all the machinery to let
machines be uncertain about the world
and it works great and that was the
beginning of modern ai
but despite that despite the admission
that uncertainty is pervasive in
everything we know about the world
we persisted with the idea that there
would still be perfect certainty about
the objectives
and i can't really explain why that was
other than that it's the standard model
and it's kind of like in biology the
central dogma
and you just don't question it
and that was a big mistake religious to
some degree yeah i think so
okay
well thank you thank you
[Music]
there's another one here
thank you
so in this part of the conversation i'm
going to ask a few questions and again
there are people with cards around if
you have a question for anybody up here
we'll start with with that
so
the idea is we have possible ideas about
possible minds i'm wondering if there's
any statement about artificial
intelligence
that the three of you would agree on
what would you think that might be
what could you say about ai
either today maybe we should praise the
best idea of the others
say it again maybe we can you know
you know maybe i can say
stewart's best idea or something okay
yeah so what's the stewart's best idea
and then i can't disagree with it okay
no i i think stuart i think stewart is
on to something about how we have us how
the standard model we get stuck with and
we got stuck with it for a long time
and
so that that idea that we keep have to
keep revisiting what the standard model
is we've got a new standard model and
all those
a few new standard models but i think
that's a good idea that we keep
revisiting that
and elsa would you agree with that i
think so i mean i think there's i think
there's an issue so here's something
that i think we would all agree about we
would all agree
that
at the that ai is
extremely powerful and smart and
extremely stupid and very far from being
smart at the same time so i think i
think all of us would agree that both of
those things are true that it's
much more powerful and more intelligent
than we might ever have thought and it's
also much stupider and much less
intelligent than we might ever have
thought so that i think that's a
contradiction that um
a whitman a walt whitman type
contradiction that we can all uh it
might might apply to some of the people
in it too that's
that's
but i think there's something
interesting about what rod was saying
about what stewart was saying which is
this question about how it is that we
design objective functions doesn't just
apply to our understanding of artificial
intelligence is of course it applies to
us too
so that was the point that i was the
huck finn point that i was making which
is one of the most curious interesting
things about human intelligence is that
we're capable of changing our minds
about what our objective functions are
yes um and machines are capable of
changing our minds about what our
objectives are
and that's part of the problem right so
you know one of the
one of the failure modes is if you if
you have a machine who's des which is
designed to solve
human problems to
satisfy human objectives the easiest way
to do that is to change the human
objectives so that they're easier to
satisfy
right and so you have to
you know make sure that that isn't a bug
in your
uh in your design because i think this
is actually one of the things they're
doing
right now and advertisers have been
doing this for
decades and decades yeah slightly
discriminate
i think
when people hear you speak they often
think you're saying and you might even
believe this i'm not sure
they often think you're saying that the
ai system is doing it volitionally but
some of the things you were talking
about before have has been done with
human assistance within the companies
and it's been very explicitly the goals
of the humans
to get the attention and to get the
click through so it hasn't been as
automatic as somehow sometimes people
would think from listening to you it's
been much more
people have been in the loop of making
that happen but i mean the
the goal of click through right so i
mean these are simple banded algorithms
and reinforcement learning algorithms
and sometimes there's a loop that passes
through humans where they do a b testing
and other kinds of things but but
basically it's the machine that's
measuring click through
uh and for each piece of content and
each person is trying to estimate the
probability that they're going to click
on that
and then continually up to updating
their estimates and so on so
so there is a
completely automated feedback loop
uh whose objective is maximization of
click through but you know we set it up
of course
but you as you said that's like 50 lines
of code so so the picture is somehow and
i think this picture is rooted in much
older anxieties is that it's because
they're so intelligent that they're
going to be scary like the golem right
or like frankenstein
uh like frankenstein's monster whereas
it's actually in some ways you know
perfectly simple not terribly
sophisticated intelligent systems that
that can do just as much damage if not
more damage
so so rod is there um
what what's the number one thing
that you think is misunderstood about ai
by the public and what is the number one
thing that's misunderstood by ai by the
experts
okay i can do the first one uh fairly
easily right
i think that
this was from my essay seven deadly sins
of predicting the future of ai i think
if we hear about a person with a certain
level of performance we understand how
to generalize that performance to what
sort of confidence they have so when um
i
hear you speaking chinese i think well
then a chinese person could probably
come up to kevin and say
talk about the weather in chinese if he
can speak chinese at all whereas the
image labeling systems that say it's a
snowplow on a snowy day don't know that
weather exists so the
the image labeling system has a
performance but the competence
generalization around that is nothing
like what we could apply to a human
the second part of the question was what
what's one thing that is misunderstood
in your opinion by most of the
oh oh oh oh they think they have the
right metaphors
to make progress
they're completely wrong
so allison what would you say to the
same questions what's what's the number
one thing that you think
is misunderstood by the public in terms
of uh understanding ai and then what's
the number one thing that you think the
experts misunderstand well this is
something that i think actually applies
to both public and the experts which is
the extent to which what ais are doing
is actually
sort of
crowdsourcing human intelligence as
opposed to generating intelligence of
their own so if you take the translation
example uh which which stuart was
mentioning and lots of people use as an
example really what's happening is that
there are you know millions of human
beings doing translations on the net and
what the
ai is doing is just trying to find
regularities in the translations but
those things would be completely
impossible if they weren't really uh
amalgamating all of the decisions of a
whole lot of human intelligences um and
the same thing's true about image
recognition so it's important that those
images are things that people have
already decided that this is a good
image of a cat and that it should be
called a cat and put it on uh before
they before they put it on the web so in
you could argue that what's really
happened is not so much about the
artificial intelligence that that's
going to come and come and get us as
what happens when you aggregate you know
millions and millions of human
intelligences and then you have some
really important algorithms and so forth
that can take advantage of that
aggregation and that's a really
different way of looking at it than
thinking there's these other there's
these aliens out here that have a
different kind of intelligence for good
or real stuart
i think what you see over and over again
in the media and
movies about ai
is that everything is completely fine as
long as they don't become conscious
right because of course when they become
conscious they will naturally hate us
and want to kill us all
so as long as and and then they usually
go on to say and of course ai
researchers have you know know nothing
whatsoever about consciousness so we
don't have anything to worry about you
need to do a lot of psychology so so
let's put it this way right
yeah no one knows anything about
consciousness um so if if if i gave you
this piece of software you know maybe in
20 years time
uh and you you read through all the code
you know you understand the programming
language you know what kind of machine
it's going to run on and i say you know
is this going to take over the world and
you read through it and you say yeah
uh you know it's when you run this code
i can see what's going to happen it's
going to start formulating these plans
and and it's going to do this and this
and this and this and this
and you say okay it's definitely gonna
take as well um
and now i say okay but
um
actually this piece of software uh
also produces a conscious entity
does that change your prediction
any answers
of course not
of course not because i made my
prediction based on
c plus code
running on you know intel x99 or
whatever it is and
um
that prediction doesn't change it's
still the same c plus plus code still
running on the same machine the fact
that you've told me that it also
produces consciousness has absolutely no
impact on my prediction that's going to
take over the world so that taking over
the worldiness
of ai systems
has nothing whatsoever to do with
consciousness and i think that's really
important for people to understand
because it means it's not science
fiction it doesn't require
some sort of completely unphysical
breakthrough it would be like saying you
know it's it's only a dangerous missile
when it goes faster than the speed of
light so since we don't since we know
that we can't go faster than speed of
light everything is safe right it's just
really annoying
and i get another i get annoyed that
that stewart uses the term
that it's going to take over the world
instead of it's going to cause mayhem
which is very different from taking over
the world
i think
one of the things that people get wrong
today
to quote stuart brand
i mean um
all all contemporary discussion is bound
to age badly and immediately without the
longer perspective
um
long now obviously but there's something
to that where so much of the
conversation today is
this is digital narrative
coming out of five companies and the
people that work there and and the
so-called
technical tech press
you know it which is is pretty much uh
not a normal press situation
you know everybody's on the same page
they're all in the calm they're all in
it together and i think that's a huge
issue
it's um
i think this goes back to the metaphors
we have we have a shortage of metaphors
of framings for this and part of i think
what we're trying to do is to see what
alternative metaphors there might be
so
um i think people work with kids
you don't normally think in
computational metaphors although you
could but you probably don't no we
always think in terms of computational
metaphors really yeah i mean we have
been destroyed science well
and that's how we made progress so you
know for the past 40 years so this this
would be the argument that i i have with
rodney for the past 40 years and rather
surprisingly in a way it turns out that
this computational
uh this computational model for
a lot of really complicated kinds of
human capacities including the kinds of
complicated capacities that we see in
even very young children just turns out
to be a scientifically extremely
productive and effective model and
that's you know that's what we wanted
science it's not like there was some a
priori
reason that we knew that it was going to
turn out to be computation and there are
lots of reasons why you might think
really you know like two-year-olds are
constructing causal graphical probable
models and then looking at conditional
probabilities and mapping them off like
that doesn't seem very likely but it's
sure enough if you want to predict the
behavior of two-year-olds that turns out
to be the best way that you could think
of doing it better than every day you're
better than your sort of everyday
psychology certainly better than any
biological simple biological
neurological account and that's true
across all of cognitive science now
maybe it's not the end our scientific
models often run out of steam at some
point but i think the remarkable thing
is that it's been as effective and and
as powerful and explanatory device says
as powerful and explanatory devices it
has been
yeah i mean if there was a
if cognitive scientists had a better
predictive model you can bet the ai
people would be using it
to make better ai systems
and there has been some i would say
interplay but when you look at the
revival of
of the whole bayesian theory of
cognition uh it's really arisen because
uh we were able to produce models that
were much much richer
than
for example some of the simple
uh psychological models of the
behaviorists and so on and able to
explain
uh really quite creative behaviors you
know the ability to to look at a new
alphabet and recognize a letter from one
example
and then we recognize it when it's you
know stitched on a quilt
um that kind of thing can be done
with these sorts of models
i think there's also something
interesting to say about turing which is
that you know that model starts out by
thinking about what someone's doing
inside of their head when they're doing
compute in particular what a woman is
doing on paper right what a woman is
doing when she's sitting there doing the
computations that that won world war
world war ii and it's well the
interesting thought is is the thing that
you do when you're sitting there and
working out a computation could you
actually use that to
build a physical system that's the great
insight and then it turns out not only
can you do that but you can do it to
explain things that don't feel like
calculation at all like uh a
two-year-old figuring out uh how what
what her her mom is thinking and you can
use it for things that look very
different so it goes back and forth
between the physical and the
psychological
yes but it's actually it's actually a
little more subtle than that even turing
wanted to show that this process
that
women computers were doing on pencil and
paper was all there was
so that he could get a contradiction in
one of hilbert's later problems he
wanted to say that's all there is
because then i can disprove this thing
so it's
but that it is a model of
people
doing physical things becoming
computational and then that becoming the
physical
instantiation in the children it's a
weird loop and i suspect we don't have
it right if we went on the long term
view of the world of science i suspect
we'll come with something different
before before
the clock
strikes ten thousand
so
i have a
question from our audience from john
gilmore he says educating humans into
self-direction takes 20 years
is a team trying now to teach an ai
system to become self-directed 20 years
from now
to your point about the phase of
childhood thinking which may be
necessary
do we imagine
that
there is a time element in intelligence
that that maybe you need to have
many many years to grow intelligence
rather than to install them or to
download them is is there
is is that a necessary
element of intelligence that there's a
time dimension
well i think one of the things that's
been really interesting about what's
happened with with things like uh deep
learning or deep rl is that the amount
of data so the the limit there's a
limitation about time but there's also a
limitation about data and one of the
interesting things is that you can get
much more data much many more rounds of
evidence in a shorter period of time
than we could than we could do before so
you know uh uh alpha zero is playing
millions and millions of chess games in
the space of
weeks and maybe even hours hours
80 million games per hour i think
something like that and obviously we're
not doing we're not getting data at
anything like that rate so the fact it
is true that just
speeding up the amount of speeding up
the rate at which we can get data is has
been relevant to those advances yeah but
this gets back to your point about um
children with one or two examples or
three examples because these learning
processes if you look at the actual
amount of energy they use yeah that's an
incredible amount of energy compared to
what a child uses to learn
because the calorie energy yeah the
actual energy you know the the carbon
footprint of these learning algorithms
is significant but then we've got this
thing that once you've learned it you
can duplicate it at almost no cost which
isn't the case
with with humans but i think um
you know
we
not only children but adults of course
learn from a very small number of
examples back in november i taught
stuart and a large audience to recognize
steampunk with only six examples
even stuart got it right
yeah so i mean actually this this was
the topic of my thesis research was how
do we generalize from one example or two
examples and
um
you know i
it's clear to me that the deep learning
community is
seeing the writing on the wall
just as
you know in the 60s the ai community got
very excited that they could come up
with three-step plans or four-step plans
and they thought oh you know we'll just
have bigger computers and then we can do
million step plans but of course
if there was exponential complexity in
those planning problems and they could
get up to like six uh and then they ran
out of steam completely and you can't
have an exponential amount of data right
there's no good saying well i have a
learning algorithm and i just need
more data than there is in the entire
universe
uh to train it that's that then i'll
have a really smart machine it just
doesn't make sense right um you know
when you when you look at something like
the detector that
uh the ligo detector that detected the
collision of two black holes you know
two thirds of the way across the
universe
um that's not built by
you know training something from you
know quintillions of other examples of
black holes colliding to the theory two
thirds of the way they had never seen in
one of those before
and um
it it is built on the basis of human
experience right of scientists going
back thousands of years but that human
experience was clearly communicated
through written knowledge because all
those people are dead i think right so
so you simply can't explain that kind of
event by saying oh we just we just get
more big data uh and we train our
machines from it it just doesn't make
sense at all it'd be like you know
another problem might be i want my
machine to to design
the next gigafactory you know the one
that they're building in china
right well
where are the four billion other
gigafactories that you're going to use
as training example for that problem
right so we all
here's a quote from demis
who's ceo of deepmind right he's
the the brain behind alphago and a lot
of other deep learning successes he says
you know we clearly have to
uh to start working on on machines that
use symbols and logic and math uh and
all that kind of thing right which ai
people worked on uh back in the 80s
so the pendulum is swinging
if you think about the example the other
i mean in a sense it's an even worse
problem because what happens is once
you've learned from those millions of
examples
you don't get very much benefit for the
next million examples so if you take the
example about chess this thing that
we've all thought was
was a tremendous sign of intelligence
even though those systems can learn from
chess if you went to the machine and you
said okay now we're going to make all
the rooks go backwards and all the
bishops are going to be able to hop over
the knights four times i want you to
play that game even a seven-year-old
would be able to say oh yeah okay i i've
got my chest skills i can apply it to i
can apply it to that game they wouldn't
have to do another million uh examples
to be able to to come back and learn it
and of course another an uh another uh
piece is that my three-year-old uh
grandson who can't play chess can knock
all the pieces off the board that's his
idea of how you play chess is knock all
the pieces off the board and then pick
them up and put them back which again is
something that uh computers aren't even
in the ballpark of being able to do so
so so it seems as if
something we can something that three of
you agree on is is the fact of the kind
of the maybe the limit of this big data
neural net approach that that's limited
in
in
some some capacity
what is something that none of the three
of you agree on what what do you
fundamentally disagree about
the most
[Laughter]
so
like do i want to start throwing out
some things and see if uh
um
that um
uh
that there's uh let's see
how about the statement that um
uh ai can be smarter than humans
how about the the statement that people
make that um
uh we need to regulate ai
right now
or that we should uh weaponize ai i'm
just i'm just throwing some statements
out just to see if i think you all agree
i think we all agree that we shouldn't
be
weaponizing ai
no i don't agree
you don't agree no i think there's a
that's a certain level of um
uh
privileged uh arrogance actually um
you know i had 6500 robots in iraq and
afghanistan
and
dealing with roadside bombs they weren't
weaponized
but
the locals we would see a new technology
arise to defeat the robots in one place
within three weeks it would spread
across the country and it was using
technology that i said at the time was
uh it was a mixture of
radio shack and home depot technology
that was before open courseware and
before um
you know
coursera and these other companies
i think when people say we the ai
practitioners must decide that it's
going to go this way there's an
arrogance that there is some privileged
people are sitting at berkeley and and
uh stanford and mit whereas the world is
full of really smart people and we have
democratized knowledge and saying that
we we control the knowledge i think is
is very misguided i don't think we
control the knowledge at all but you
know
the knowledge of how to make chemical
weapons is not controlled everyone knows
how to do that but nonetheless we have
regulation to ban it and i'm glad we do
uh
there's regulations on the delivery
systems but um i think i think that you
have to be careful what you're
regulating especially if you're going to
say we're going to regulate ai we're
going to regulate our ai research which
some of your friends have said
no actually toby has said um
my question is what do you want to
change right now what behavior of what
person do you want to change what do you
want to say that
stuart is allowed to do in his in his
office that has to change if you want to
regulate it i think you want to regulate
outcomes but not methods
yeah you don't want ai systems that can
decide to kill humans and i think that's
you know that even there
no no it's actually not common sense um
and this is not going to be a popular
position but um
i have thought about this a lot um
there's
an
understanding
or there's a an expectation that because
a machine is involved in a decision
things are worse but what we did as a
country united states put
young kids just out of high school in
villages at night
in very dangerous situations
what is their option their option is to
protect themselves they're scared beyond
belief
a robot can afford to shoot second a
person we don't expect our 18 year olds
to to do that yeah so
you know as as we can use it can change
the dynamics
i've put many robots out
going into
hostage situations where the robots go
out there and it changes the dynamics
it's not this simple minded idea robots
making decisions robots in a feedback
loop are bad
we have our machines making decisions
all the time we have our machines
deciding when to put our brakes on with
automatic braking systems when they
first came out say oh we can't allow the
we can't allow the
the the
uh car to decide when to break or not
but it's much better than the human
being in that loop so
therefore if it's a machine it's bad
it's a naive thing to say
but i didn't say that so francis
you want us to argue we got there okay
right
so that that's that's a that's you're
over generalizing from what i'm saying
just because there are possible good
uses
uh of lethal autonomous weapons
doesn't mean that it's a good idea to
have them proliferate across the whole
world in the hope that everyone will
only use them for those good things but
by the way by the way they're out
autonomous lethal weapons are out there
everywhere
already um and it's not from the elites
deciding to build them it's from
ordinary people around the world
deciding to build them
uh
no the ones that the ones they're
building are remotely piloted and not oh
no no no no no that was not true in iraq
and i understand they were not
necessarily remotely operated at all
they were automatic systems they were
there well here's here's something that
we might disagree about but that's
relevant
which is how much is this discontinuous
with other
technologies and both you know
technologies in the fancy machine sense
but also sort of social technologies
like our abilities to read or
communicate how much how much is what's
happened with ai
really discontinuous with that or how
much is it continuous with the fact that
we've always had to regulate uh you know
we regulate dishwashers and cuisinarts
and
uh until we regulated electricity it
killed lots of people i mean there's
there's a sense so this is a question
it's how much of this is really
something that's completely different
from everything that we've had done
before and how much is it a matter of
regulating our own understanding so
social media i think this is an example
that cuts both ways when you talk about
social media there's a wonderful book
called the uh the literary underground
and the austrian regime and there's very
clear evidence that when printing really
became became easy and efficient it
totally changed the way that people
communicated in exactly with exactly the
kind of reinforcement algorithms that
you're talking about so there was this
sudden proliferation of
political scandal and pornography and it
was you know the only bad outcome was
the french revolution but aside from
that
um
aside from that it was kind of okay in
the long run in the long run and the
american revolution yeah
right i mean the french revolution and
the american revolution well you know
kind of trade off and in the long run
everything was okay so i you know i
really do wonder how much
how much you think that and we write and
we pass libel laws because
if you and i think the scalability is
the important
thing
right and um you know pharmaceutical
companies
have this property of scalability right
once they formulate a new drug they can
they can make it by the billions of
pills um and if it turns out
you know two years later that everyone
who took one of those pills is gonna die
um that would be really bad and so
we actually have many many stages of
control to prevent that from happening
because it did happen right there were
there were episodes of hundreds of
thousands of people dying or being
paralyzed from misformulated products
um
and
uh
you know now with social media right we
also have a sort of scalable
weapon of social destruction and uh
you know there's nothing between you
know four undergrads chugging red bull
and the world population
right
uh there's no layers of control there's
no there's no stage one trial stage two
trial nothing
and i would say silicon valley thinks
that's great
um
but at some point the rest of the world
is going to say this is not great no and
i agree with you on this i i think i
think that the and this sort of gets to
your point the
the labeling that ai per se is is is
vastly different is is i think misguided
and it's a different level of control
that we need i mean i think there is a
kind of mythology that
uh and again this goes back to the golem
right is that things that are kind of
like human beings that are it's
interesting for instance have you
noticed that we've stopped saying ai and
we started saying anna ai or the air i
have
no i completely agree with you but i
think it's symptomatic because there is
no there is no nai there aren't there
are no ex there are no examples of
existence
i do think there's there's an overlay of
something that's always been true about
human beings which is that this very
capacity that we have to reshape our
objectives and reshape the way that we
think about the world has this it's
always a is always a a double-edged
sword yeah and when we when we when we
see as you said i think the words you
used were when we see that something is
sort of like us but not exactly us then
we become afraid but it's sort of like
immigrants you know yeah well
they will all want to kill us because
as immigrants uh australians yes
yes
but but i think that's that general
symptom so right but if you're a gorilla
right you know
you could say all these humans yeah
they're sort of like us but you know
that that's just uh you know we're just
treating that treating them like you
know those low land gorillas those
immigrant lowland gorillas you know was
wrong of us to discriminate against the
lowland gorillas and and we should
welcome humans with open arms but the
gorillas
lost
right these immigrants the humans were
just smarter
and they destroyed
almost all the gorillas almost all the
chimpanzees so almost all the whales
and lots and lots of intelligence old
mammals except cows
pretty much so lots and lots of
intelligent species got wiped out or
almost wiped out because they weren't
quite as intelligent as us so um
so yes it's possible coming back to your
earlier question yes it's possible to be
smarter than a human in the same way
that it's possible to be smarter than a
chimpanzee or a whale or but i don't
know i think that's exactly wrong i
think i think what's happened is that
we're smarter than we were
this is the flynn effect right i mean
the fact that we communicate with one
another the fact that we've invented
things like printing has made us
much smarter than we were in the past so
it isn't quite like what's happened is
that we eliminated all of our agrarian
ancestors somehow right i mean we don't
think okay i mean the australian amber
the australian aborigines eliminated all
of the large mammals in australia
uh long before they had the printing and
then the british eliminated right and
everything
so
um
yeah you know so and but we are capable
of producing this technology of mass
elimination and the gorillas aren't
uh and that matters so they have bigger
short-term memories than us
they can remember more digits of a
telephone number than we can but didn't
help them very much
so i'd like to to wrap this up with one
final question for the three of you
individually which is
give us a very brief view of the
long-term
view of ai so ai in the next
you know long term what do you think is
is this is this is this um
when you look ahead 100 years a thousand
years is it
what do you see do you see
um
increasing well just tell me what you
see
so
so rod and i actually agree that we are
still a long way from anything yeah uh
and alice as well we all agree that
we're a long way from anything
resembling
human level or what might call general
purpose intelligence something that
could you know quickly learn any task
that a human could put their mind to and
and master it
um
and we need conceptual breakthroughs
it's definitely not we need bigger
machines i mean bigger machines just
give you the wrong answer more quickly
so
we need these conceptual breakthroughs
and
those are very unpredictable
and it could be that they come pretty
quickly i mean what's happening
now is a massive increase in the
investment
uh into ai research a huge influx of
incredibly bright
young students and and people from other
fields
so i think the rate of
progress is accelerating
so i would say i'd be completely shocked
if it happened in the next decade
but i wouldn't be at all surprised if it
happened within this century and i think
that's the consensus of the vast
majority of the ai researchers
that happen so the it would be
it would be that we have then machines
um
and they're not going to be like humans
right it's not like we're going to say
okay now it's reached the level
uh you know iq 75 iq 90. uh there's a
completely ridiculous idea
right uh as soon as they can read
they'll be able to read everything the
human race has ever written
and ingest all that knowledge and
understand it so they're not gonna look
like humans in any way shape or form
um
and they they will be tools beyond your
wildest dreams
right if they have physical embodiment
uh you'll be able to say you know i need
a house
and you have a house
right i need
i need some information about the
history of
uh of some ancient civilization you know
you have it uh
and
you know one simple way of thinking
about it is if we had such machines you
know forget about the science fiction
stuff they you know they would invent
eternal life and faster than light
transportation just could if they
brought the
standard of living of everyone on earth
up to a kind of respectable
bay area level
[Music]
that would be you know you calculate the
net present value that it will come to
about 20 thousand trillion dollars who's
got all the machines
right so
there's going to be uh my people
uh i know there's go so
if we navigate all these problems if we
if we figure out how to make sure that
despite the fact that these things are
more powerful than us that we have power
and they don't forever
if we solve that problem
uh then
you could have a golden age as long as
you can figure out what human
what the human race is for okay
so that's that i think is going to be
the problem
that's very very vivid thank you for
taking that time in detail i know it's
really hard to do and we're reluctant to
so allison do you have a vision
of the long-term vision
so the first thing to say is one of the
things about being a mother and caring
about children is you learn that you
should ration your worries that there's
always an infinite space of things to
worry about so you should pick your
battles when it comes to useless worry
so if you want to worry i think we could
worry about climate change all the time
24 7 leave nothing around to leave no
space to worry about ai and we still
wouldn't be wearing enough so that's
kind of my maternal that's my maternal
advice um
but i also think this is perhaps a bit
different from stuart that if you look
at our history i think what will happen
is that will change in all sorts of
serious important ways and we won't
notice it because what always happens is
that the day before you're born is
always eaten and the things that happen
to you in your own life span are always
technology
and the day after your children are born
is always mad max right so we always are
in this situation where we think that
the things that happen to us are
technological innovations and they're
probably going to end up being mad max
but then of course if we think about the
things like the fact that in this room
there are right angles everywhere it
it's not like we're really sitting there
saying my god the right angles the right
angles are taking over everywhere
everywhere we look there's
um
that's
even though the fact of right angles has
made enormous changes in our lives or
the fact that there's print everywhere
doesn't strike us as being something
that's this weird technology that we're
constantly getting distracted because we
have to figure out what that r is right
that's just that's just part of our
lives and i suspect what will happen is
we'll change in really deep and profound
ways and we won't notice it because
it'll be happening over and across
generations that's fantastic thank you
well i i guess i i just want to thank
stuart for giving another example of my
seven deadly sins of predicting ai that
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic and i think
you know when it's magic it can be as
bad as you want um so i disagree with
stuart i wrote a book for
i wrote a book for for for for um
for john um back in 2002 and it was
named by katinka called flesh and
machines where i thought and i still
think but i had the time scale
completely wrong i thought that we are
going to change and we have changed with
our external devices but i talked there
about how we humans will change by
ingesting new technology into our into
our bodies we had cochlear implants
already i thought that that
process was going to continue somewhat
quite a bit faster that has happened i
didn't foresee crispr and christmas may
well change us so i think we will change
ourselves
in explicit ways and so i don't quite
see that there's going to be ai and us
as separate things but we will change
ourselves as we go forward and that's
the long term that we will see
so
i want to thank you all for your
presence here for your contributions
um i think we had a vision of possible
minds i want to thank you for bringing
your own mind here and um sharing with
us i want to thank the audience for
joining us with this exploration and
with that we have to conclude so thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
you